you know it's cold outside and there's
nothing better on a weekend when it's
cold than making a stew am i right
everybody a soup we can put whatever you
have in the fridge in it and keep it
cooking for a few hours uh we're gonna
make today something i call a stew berry
more yes
i named it after my friend drew well
you've already started it off first of
all thank you i really love that name
yeah me too i love a hearty stew too and
you're already starting with a fantastic
mirepoix yeah so i already browned some
like
stew meat you know some steak here i
browned it earlier into some olive oil
but then in the same pan with a little
more oil i do the mirepoix the garlic
the onion the celery i'm gonna put a
little salt and pepper in here as well
and then i always like a little heat in
my food just a little bit so i'm doing
some crushed red pepper hey something
else i add in here it's one of your
favorite ingredients too
celery salt it's my favorite there's
something about it it's just celery seed
mixed with salt but it's grassy a little
bitter kind of sweet too it adds depth
to everything grassy is the perfect
description absolutely so now that these
are sort of sweated through i'm going to
add some garlic and the reason i add
this later is because garlic can burn if
you're not careful and i know i like it
all right well now we're going to take
our beef stock and this is just what is
this four cups or so
mix this in once once the onions are
translucent
and then are you ready for my mom's tip
my mom made the best stew in the entire
world there we are together my mom
and she taught me uh something that does
like it takes stew to the next level you
guys look at this this is v8 juice oh
and wait till you taste what this does
to our stew well first of all i'm so
excited to bring your mom here into the
kitchen rossi i know you know this this
is something we would make um a lot she
she hated wasting so she would always
use the vegetables and she was like such
a hearty chef not fancy but just like
always cooked with love and so i taste i
taste her when i cook stuff like that
and she raised you with so much love
thank you thank you
[Applause]
raising you and you carry her love you
carry her heart and your heart and we
all get to reap the benefits of all that
goodness between you and your mom thank
you
thank you
isn't that funny
i think we can all relate food does that
right it brings memories back senses
back and it can bring people back
sometimes you know just a little bit
okay now give me a tissue and we're
gonna keep cooking okay
i'm gonna add some um
frozen peas i love doing frozen peas
because they defrost in like 10 seconds
when you put them and then there's just
this burst of brightness in in the stew
um so now this is normally when you
would add like your potatoes or your
noodles yep but i don't know if you
noticed hi i'm trying i'm in the fight
i'm working it out
and so oops i'm also spilling okay
instead of a noodle or potato what about
this
just some white beans oh juices i don't
want you to slip thank you so much
can you guys look at her underneath the
table thank you
that's a friend man
that is a friend rosie's not slipping on
my watch
all right thank you well what i have
here white beans so instead of the
potato or noodle and these have actual
like nutrients they're good for you
they're not a complex carb is this a
cannellini this is a can of lady i like
a cake
it's a it's actually two cans of
cannellini and i left some of the bean
juice in there why that's what i was
going to ask you do you juice or no
juice uh in this scenario if i'm making
like a bean salad or something i take
the juice out but in this scenario that
starchy bean juice thickens up the stew
yeah it does let's add our um beef back
in now
and this is my favorite part you're just
going to stir it
put a lid on and walk away for a couple
hours with this on low so we actually
have a pot here that's been cooking for
a couple hours and you can see look how
thick and yummy this looks you guys
so spoon yourself up
a nice bowl
this is so gorgeous i can't believe i'm
lucky enough to eat this raw potato well
thank you so much you'll notice here i
just finished it
i finished it with a little sour cream
and some chives oh yeah i got right in
on that and now i can taste my mom's
trick ready make sure we blow on it
before we burn our mouths
[Music]
you don't even have to say it i already
know
well what's funny is um not only am i so
happy to taste a recipe
but honor your mom yeah i'm happy to
have this memory with you i love you i
love you too
[Music]